you
my whole life I wanted to beam you know
Junior Seau nobody else I wanted to be
like my uncle everything that he's done
from his foundation to the way he acted
the way he treated people just hearing
my name on drive day you know I wanted
my grandparents to be there and my uncle
to be there everybody that you know that
I hold close to me to be there and the
fact that he's not there just having
this moment with him because that's the
way be connected is going to be the most
emotional moment to me sob uncle bug dr
days in a couple weeks man hopefully we
make it happen but working a lot for
this man ever since he was grinding on
the beach with everybody starting his
day was hopefully we could do it on
growing up I go into his house and I
just see trophies on trophies and
jerseys most inspirational player at VP
he had a picture of him shaking
President George Bush's hand I was just
sitting there like jealous this dudes
making a living on the field he was a
beast just giving up his body showing so
much passion and love for the game sort
of what you would want out of a football
player especially out of a veteran my
uncle influenced a lot of people but the
way he influenced me directly is just
work ethic my uncle is a very
hard-working guy he wasn't really
telling me about the X's and O's of
football but just working hard because
that's really what's going to get you to
where you want to be as an individual Jr
would privately call Ian and give him
heads-up like counseling advice and or
just say hey good job
leaving Kansas thing going back to
Grossmont a place that's home place
that's familiar it was it was an
interesting situation at that point in
my life went back home you know a couple
months later Michael obviously passed
away rest in peace to him this is a
suicide investigation at jr. sayo died
from a self-inflicted song
self-inflicted gunshot wound to the
chest
and took it hard and I think it still
hurts him I think it still hurts him
that he's gone because he doesn't get
that phone call anymore coping with my
my hero my person I idolized passing
away it really just took a huge toll on
me and I didn't really know what to do
took a couple months off and the Markel
was actually a linebacker coach at
Grossmont talked to me about it and we
sort of just decided to go with the flow
when the Grossmont first game college of
the desert boom five six sacks I was
like you know what ma'am I'll just stick
with this one in the next week four
sacks I was like you know I'm just going
to play football see what I could do
with it I always asked him as well as I
do God you know please protect me give
me your strength and uncle man if you if
you still want to play a man play
through me and let's go make some plays
this story that I know a lot of people
were talking about a number of months
ago talking about jr. sale now this team
of scientists who analyzed his brain
tissue have discovered he had a
debilitating brain disease doctors
believe the former NFL all-star
linebacker who took his own life that
was just last May had this disease it's
known as CTE caused by two decades of
taking hard hit to his head after that
came out a lot of people my family
didn't really want anybody playing
football or anything like that I am
scared of Ian's life but when I watch
him play he does take good care of
himself out in the football field I sit
back and I think about my brain all the
time I'm cautious about the concussions
especially after what happened mark
obviously and I'm not really worried
from that aspect because once I start
seeing signs then I'll know to walk away
from the game so my family on their
ideas of me playing in the NFL all over
the place they all want to support me
and you know tell me and it's okay if
you don't want to play but if you do
we'll support you I just want to see if
I can do this that says I just want to
go out there and show people I can make
it my mom she doesn't want me to play
but she's obviously supporting me and
may not have that like look like my
brother but ian has the heart like my
brother junior on draft day you know if
my name gets called and I get that phone
call and saying you're coming here i'ma
sit there and just you know just think
to myself everyone's probably be happy
you slapping me and saying good job man
were proud of you and all our stuff and
then I probably go somewhere maybe go to
my uncle's grapes and just sit there
just me and him and talk and you know
just have a man we did it right now he's
looking down and saying how proud he is
of him
moving on not living negative things
bring him down
with what he had done junior is happy
right now he is so happy that he that
ian has continued on moving forward that
he's the only one that didn't just stop
I feel like monkey would be proud just
because I never gave up like like I said
before I spend a lot of time idolizing
my uncle wrote papers about him and
doing all these things so finally being
in this position - to actually do it
puts me in a position you say aye uncle
thank you for it I sort of motivating me
and inspiring me to actually do
something with my life